[Music]
foreign
since the Winter Gardens has come back
under the control of the council there
have been many rumors that the building
will be closed for Good this is
absolutely not true what it does allow
us to do is to take an in-depth look at
what is the best possible future for the
building and this opportunity could not
have come at a better time as you may
know we've been allocated over 22
million pounds of government funding
through the Malya Town deal now 300 000
pounds of this is to do a detailed study
to understand a market currently but
also the competition and what may need
to be done structurally with this
building and also the best way of going
forward for the future of the Winter
Gardens Margate Town deal funding is
crucial in acting as seed funding to
support the continued regeneration of
Margate it means we can start delivering
on regeneration projects driving
long-term economic growth and
productivity we need a Leisure offer for
both residents and visitors something
that brings people into the town and
supports our Performing Arts a
destination in its own right the Winter
Gardens is such an important asset to
Margate and the people of Margate that
we really need to take our time to get
this process right the building's not
available for use at the moment to give
us the time and space that we need to do
a thorough appraisal the security
measures that you see around the site
are there temporarily to protect the
building from damage or vandalism or
deterioration they include the temporary
screening that you see as well as daily
visits to the site periodic internal
inspections and improve CCTV all
designed to help protect the building
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
to take a step back and look with fresh
eyes at the future of the Winter Gardens
it is crucial that we use this time and
funding to determine a clear and
long-term future for the venue and to
put it back at the heart of Senate's
thriving mix of Heritage culture and
tourism
[Music]